mike is in indianapolis hey mike welcome
to the ramsay show how can christina
help
hi so this is kind of surreal talking to
you on the phone
it's okay i'm glad you're here brother
my family
um but i need to hear it from your lips
okay um over the last year
my wife and i have paid off all of our
debt with the exception of the mortgage
and eight thousand dollars in student
loans okay
since then um we have been able to put
about eighteen thousand dollars in the
bank
just because i was officer kovit for
seven weeks and it scared us
okay now we need some upgrades to our
house
including new windows we bought a 45
year old house windows are original to
the home
but i still have 8 000 in student loans
do i write the check and get rid of them
and then do the
improvements to the house or can i go
ahead and give my wife new windows
well you know the answer you
the biggest problem is that in the
winter where we live is so rural we have
propane heat
and the windows leak so bad that it cost
us yeah
how long have you lived there uh six
years
when i know
by the way this is what month
it's but it's still cold up here i know
so on
it's not it's not it's not going to be
cold but another month
right so this has nothing we're not even
heading into weather
not gonna work mike okay by the way
by the way what are the windows cost
yeah that's what i was like how much of
the windows how much have you gotten
savings
18 000 and the windows are going to cost
6 500. okay so what is your emergency
fund fully funded
what should it be three to six months of
expenses three to six months of expenses
should be at three months we would be
right around six thousand dollars
we were very lean okay so eighteen minus
eight is ten
minus six for your emergency fund leaves
four why can you not have the windows in
by next fall
i don't know what's your household
income
uh so it's just me we homeschool our
kids what's your household income take
take almost 43 000. but that also
includes
um i have a company car and the company
pays for all of my
uh vehicle maintenance gaps everything
so i don't have a
travel budget for for work very nice
okay
well so um but i mean
let i think you ought to put in windows
by the fall
and i think you're gonna have an
emergency i think you're gonna pay off
your student loan today
you keep your emergency fund aside and
anything above your emergency fund will
drag over to a different savings account
and that's the window savings account
you take on an extra job you have a
garage sale you do whatever else to have
the difference
in and have your windows ready to
purchase uh before it gets cold
you know i think mike i think you i
think coveted scared y'all a little bit
i think you stocked up this cash of 18
000 i think you liked having the cushion
of 18 000 and now the thought of
spending some of the 18 000 on windows
or your debt
scares you because you like having the
18 000. and i just want you know you're
gonna be okay
you can pay off your loans you can get
your windows you can refill
your emergency fund you're gonna be okay
it's gonna be lower than you're used to
because you're used to having this 18
000.
but you have it for that reason to use
it for things you need and you need this
you need to pay off your loans and you
get those windows by fall
and you're still gonna have money for
your emergency fund
and you keep filling it up right
alrighty thank you guys so much
you can do it you can do it and she can
do it
you guys are gonna make it and and yeah
you're not you know
so you're gonna have one more month of
coolish weather
and you you're probably gonna survive it
it's pretty amazing you made it for six
years
so i get like that about stuff in my
house it's like i'm fine
it's fine for five years and then i see
it and i just can't unsee it and i
become a one-track mind
and you have to remind yourself i lived
with this for this long we don't need
this right now it's not it did not
become an emergency yesterday because we
decided
oh my gosh the windows you've lived with
it we're going into summer you'll be
fine but sometimes you see something
like oh man you just fixate on it my
next book is going to be called the
death of the drama queen
because there's a drama queen that lives
inside of every one of you it's just the
guy
right there's a drama queen inside of
all of us we all do that yeah what you
talked about there i've done it
yep i may have done it this week and
it's just monday right
but uh we all have this drama queen that
lives inside of us it's like
oh god the propane is just going out the
window
where is he we all do that crap right
yes
and once we decide we fixate on it and
there's something about this little
child on the cereal aisle that wakes up
and throws a fit
i can't live with those windows another
day and they live inside of us and this
little
child makes our decisions it's like
and we just have this little hissy fit
and that's a southern term
sounds just like yankees don't even know
what that means a hissy fit
it's like a duck fit those are two
non-yankee terms right there
but it just means your emotions got out
of control because you're immature i'll
help you with that okay
oh my goodness